[Musique]
et la tourte et rend pas oui on va voir
on a quoi sert il
est-ce que vous la voyez oui les chéris
je vous ai olivier athimon bien thibault
et vous avez promis que je serai sur tf1
ce soir et je vais y être pour longtemps
les cherry sur tf1 mon thibault comment
ça va quoi ça a pas mal pris parce qu
est ce que tu peux me dire où je dois
appuyer
alors bien bas bien von ah ben non il va
tacler tf1 va te voilà avec nous les
donne avec tous les chiffres venez avec
nous les cherry est ce qu'on peut faire
imploser général pour montrer bien la
tour d'edf a soupé les chéris regardez
regardez la tour de tf1
est-ce que vous m'entendez mais au nom
mais voilà on voit création de tf1 mon
type hot avec moi je vous avais dit que
je serai sur tf1 ce soir rien et
truquées et tous les gens qui vont
passer pour voir ça je me demander de
faire un décompte avec moi thibault et
parce que je devrai appuyé
là
attention ça craque k23 hype et des
cages seront rares tu sais je sais
[Applaudissements]
il est gentil passera dans la rue tous
les gens qui passent sur l'affairé ferry
tous les gens qui passent en voiture
bonjour ça combien de temps on va tenir
les chiens je requiers france et dans le
sud
[Applaudissements]
c'est le meilleur tour du monde les gars
regardez moi cette tt il faut savoir que
tous les gens qui vont passer vont
croire qu'il ya une nouvelle jolie sur
tf1 avec moi mon site vous appartient
c'est énorme
on a réussi la chaîne
mais si je vous dis ça mais c'est la
foule
la police tout le monde doit appeler
qu'est ce que c'est que ces conneries
pourquoi on doit la photo d'anna aussi
vous appartient pour l'instant ça tient
on attend à mon avis la police va
arriver dans un verre d'eau parce qu'on
a pris un rétroprojecteur en fait et je
vous avais promis je serai sur tf1 j'y
suis allé sur têt
oui les chéris voilà c'est réussi on
hâte dans la sécurité tf1 on va se
retrouver dans un instant les cherry
pour la suite et la fin de baba normal
activity la suite on va passer avec des
voix y en avait plein de choses et
durera isabelle morini-bosc en
lévitation mettez la en place elle va
faire un truc de ouf et pour le moment
on fera des points aux simulations sur
la tour tf1 quand ils vont arrêter ce
mascara qui vont arrêter cette mascarade
aller à tout de suite mes chéris ces
options
[Applaudissements]